well the weather is warming up local
theaters are reopening and we're getting
ready to head into the summer
blockbuster movie season
joining us now to talk all about it is
jeff carter senior editor
at las vegas weekly thank you so much
for joining us here today
hey good to see you all right jeff so
we've got all these big films
on the schedule we're talking about top
gun black widow another space jam movie
the list goes
on and on and on so my question is is
this the beginning
of las vegas return to the movie
theaters do you think that
we're ready i sincerely hope so well i
think you know
i don't want to step on the cdc's toe
they say we're ready i'd sure like to go
back myself
i like the the movies are certainly
there and the studios are going all out
definitely and we're all very excited to
get back into the theaters and be
watching all these
amazing movies here that we've been
waiting for so long to see now what
movies might locals be most interested
in
well we've got uh two marvel movies
we've got black widow which was held
over from last summer
and uh sanchi coming out later in the
year
uh suicide squad fast and the furious
nine another saw movie
another purge movie a new the new space
jam which you mentioned
um it's really an embarrassment of
riches because we have the stuff that
was coming out this summer but also the
stuff that's been held over
right so i mean we've been all at home
watching on demand
uh streaming everything so just how
important is it to actually get out
there
and enjoy the films out in the movie
theaters right now
i think it's very important i i think of
movies as a shared experience i mean
you think about going to see avengers
movies or star wars movies the moments
where everybody cheers or everybody you
know
or horror movies where everybody you
know gasps together
you know you don't realize this stuff is
gone until you you know
sat and watched it on your phone for an
entire year
you know it's uh you don't feel the
excitement around you
watching it at home definitely i feel
like it's all that momentum when you're
watching an action movie or
a scary movie and everyone kind of joins
in on the excitement so
a classic drive-in is always another fun
option especially for families and west
wing in north las vegas still
has some pretty good crowds throughout
the pandemic do you think people are
still going to
be going that route now that movie
theaters are making a comeback
i hope so i hope this is you know
exposed to people what a
great experience it is going to we have
a wonderful vintage drive-in in north
las vegas
and uh you know maybe a lot of people
you know didn't think of it as an option
you know
when regular theaters were open but you
know because of distancing they
they considered it and it's it's really
it's a different kind of experience than
seeing things in the theater it's it's
more
i guess sentimental more uh yeah you
it's
a combination of you know being outside
and watching a movie
there's nothing like watching your
favorite film on the big screen whether
it's inside the movie theaters or in the
driving well
make sure to pick up a copy of the
latest las vegas weekly
issue it's gonna have so much on the
summer movie outlook and some pretty
cool
cover art thank you so much jeff for
taking your time and talking to us about
all this